The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, good afternoon.
Today we want to wrap
up our discussion
on two-photon processes.
And just to repeat my motivation
that in almost all cases
when you address atoms,
you do two photon courses
because a photon is scattered.
You may think it's
absorbed and emitted,
but in reality, it is a
two photon process and not
two single photon processes.
So therefore, you should
really pay attention.
If you have any doubts about
some subtleties about how
is light absorbed and
emitted, the correct answer
is always obtained from
the two-photon picture.
Now, I'm using
pre-written slides
because we treat two-photon
absorption in perturbation
theory.
And it is exactly the
same perturbation theory
we've used before.
It's just-- there's
one difference.
Namely, we have two optical
fields at frequency omega 1
and omega 2.
So for the case of two-photon
absorption-- that means
both photons are used or
stacked up to go up in energy.
We derived this result, and
this was the end of lecture
last week.
And what we obtained
in perturbation theory
for the excited
state, it's exactly
the same structure
you have seen before.
But the only difference
is we have now four terms
because we have combinations
of omega 1 and omega 2,
or we can take two photons
out of the same laser beam.
Just sort of a question,
just to sort of
indicate to you
how many terms you
would expect when you do
the most basic light atom
interaction.
Just one photon, a plus a dega.
How many terms do you get if
you write down the Hamiltonian?
No approximation without.
How many do you get?
AUDIENCE: Four.
PROFESSOR: Four.
You have a plus dega for the
electric field, sigma plus plus
sigma minus for the atom.
And then you have
four combinations,
two are co-rotating, two
are counter-rotating.
OK.
What we are doing here is
second order perturbation theory
with two optical fields.
If you would not do any
rotating wave approximation,
how many terms would we get?
AUDIENCE: Eight.
PROFESSOR: Eight?
I think it's
multiplicative because we
have four processes
involving one-- oops.
Now I'm getting confused.
I wanted to say 16, 4 times 4.
But now I would say in
the first step, which
is to the intermediate level,
we have four at frequency one,
four at frequency,
which makes eight.
But then I think in the second
step you get eight more.
So if we don't make an
approximation, we get 64 terms.
But they're just
all combinations,
all combinations of frequencies.
Anyway, therefore, I
hope you appreciate
that I did the rotating
wave approximation.
I said I'm only interested
in the near-resonant terms.
And then when we say we want to
go up in energy in two steps.
We absorb two photos.
We don't have any
emission of photons.
These are all the
counter-rotating terms.
You have only the
absorption of photons,
and then we have
four possibilities.
Yes, I mean, you
have a term where
two photons are emitted
from the ground state.
This is sort of now
doubly counter-rotatable.
We're not going there.
It's not adding
anything new to it.
You know what
counter-rotating terms mean.
In this chapter on
two photons, I'm
completely focused on
the resonant terms.
But since four terms
is still too many,
I want to just tell you what
is special about two photons.
I focus now on a
situation, and that's
the most common situation in
the laboratory, where there
is a near-resonant
intermediate state
and that is sort of now
filtering out one of the terms.
If this intermediate state
is resonant with omega 1,
then we only want
to consider now
the process where the first
step to the intermediate step
is driven by the field
e1 and the second step
to the final state b is
driven by the field e2.
So therefore, we
have only one term,
which dominates
out of those four,
or dominates out
of those 64, which
we would have gotten
without any approximation.
It's one term-- the
near-resonant term--
which dominates.
So that's what we
want to discuss now.
So this is the term
we want to consider.
And it's the same we've
always done in lowest order
perturbation, second
order perturbation theory,
in two steps.
It's now in two steps.
But if you're asking, what is
the transition probability?
The transition
probability, we have
to get the probability to
be in the excited state.
And then we have
the usual situation
that this term can be written
as the sine squared divided
by this, and it turns into
a delta function times t.
And when we divide the
probability, the amplitude
squared by t, we get a rate.
And this is Fermi's Golden Rule.
It is exactly the same you have
seen probably more than 100
times.
So therefore, we have
now a transition rate,
which is Fermi's Golden Rule.
This is the delta function.
I called it the
function f because I
want to discuss the
spectral profile a minute.
But then-- and this
is the only difference
to Fermi's Golden Rule
with a signal photon--
the relevant matrix element
is, because we have two steps,
is the product of two matrix
elements squared for step one
and for step two.
And because we have
an intermediate step,
we have to divide by
the energy mismatch
by the detuning in the
intermediate state.
But remember, in the
one photon picture,
Fermi's Golden Rule
is the matrix elements
squared times the
spectral function.
So in this matrix element
squared in frequency units,
neglecting factors of 2,
was the Rabi frequency.
So therefore, very
naturally, we want
to define this as a
two-photon Rabi frequency
whereas each matrix element
here divided by h bar
was the single photon
Rabi frequency.
So therefore, what we obtained
for the two photon processes,
we have a two-photon
Rabi frequency,
which is the product of
the single photon Rabi
frequency for each step,
divided by the energy detuning
from the immediate state.
So therefore, our
result looks almost
indistinguishable from the
result built on single photons.
We've just cleverly
defined our quantities.
The rate to go from a
to b is Rabi frequency
squared, but it is the
two photon Rabi frequency.
And the delta
function is the delta
function for the resonance-- the
energy difference between state
a and b-- but now not
just minus omega 1.
It is minus the sum of
omega 1 plus omega 2
because we have stacked up the
two photons in the two photon
process.
So let me just write that down.
It looks like the
one photon excitation
but with suitably
defined Rabi frequencies.
So in other words, if
you were interested just
in the physics of two
levels-- Rabi oscillation,
you name it-- you can just
say the same thing happens.
The only difference is that
instead of having a coupling
directly by a matrix
element, we are now
coupled by this two
photon Rabi frequency.
And all your equation,
you know, everything--
you can consider line
shape, spontaneous emission,
saturation-- all the
phenomena we have discussed
for single photon are analogous.
You just have to use the density
of state calculated for the two
photons and you have to use
the two photon Rabi frequency.
OK.
So I started out by telling you
about two photon processes, two
photon absorption.
But what is maybe even
more important in the way
how it is used in experiments
are Raman processes.
So let me just show what I mean.
If you have a
state a and b, this
can be two different vibrational
states of a molecule.
It can be two hyperfine
states of an atom.
Or if you think about
a break process,
it could be the
same internal state
of the atom-- the same
hyperfine state-- but with two
different momenta.
Then it is a Raman process
only in the external degree
of freedom, in the
motion away function.
The only change is you
change the momentum.
We need our intermediate
state, which is often
an electronically excited state.
We are detuned.
And now we have one photon going
up and one photon going down.
Historically, people distinguish
between the situation
where the final state is
lower or higher in energy.
One is called the
Stokes process.
The other one is
called anti-Stokes.
But as long as you use
laser beams to stimulate it,
you don't even care which state
is higher or lower in energy.
But if you work in molecules
with a thermal ensemble,
then you have certain
states thermally populated
and others not.
And then it makes a
difference whether you
start from the ground state
a or from an excited state b.
OK.
So actually, everything
for the Raman process
is completely analogous-- is
completely covered, actually--
by what I wrote down for
you in perturbation theory.
It's just if you had kept
all the 64 states-- to go up
with one photon and down with
one photon one was one of them,
but we discarded
it because we were
only interested in going up.
So in other words,
what was previously
one of the
counter-rotating terms,
where omega had a plus sign and
omega two had a minus sign, now
it becomes a resonant
term because we
have arranged our two
levels a and b in such a way
that the near-resonant
process is that one.
So in other words,
I mention it to you
and it's just getting too
messy to write it down,
when we have e to the i omega
t and e to the minus i omega t,
I mentioned once to you is
the sign plus or minus means
whether we absorb a photon
or whether we emit a photon.
If you use a fully quantized
picture with a and a degas,
the a for the
quantized description
becomes an e to the i omega t.
In the semi-classical
description of the
a dega has a minus sign.
So therefore, if you look
at all the combinations
between plus i omega t, minus i
omega t, for this Raman process
we want to select e to the minus
omega i and e to the plus omega
too.
And that means we are
focusing on this process.
Therefore, everything
for the Raman process
is analogous to the
two-photon absorption process.
The only thing we
have to do is we
have to change the sign
on the second frequency
because the second photon is
emitted in a stimulated way
and not absorbed.
And therefore, our
detuning is the detuning
from the Raman resonance.
And therefore, OK, back
to Fermi's Golden Rule--
the rate in Fermi's Golden
Rule is the matrix element
squared times the
spectral density indicated
by the delta function.
The delta function is
now at the frequency,
which is given by the
two-photon detuning.
And the two-photon
Rabi frequency
is exactly the same what we
had for two-photon absorption,
the product of single-photon
Rabi frequencies
divided by the detuning.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, we
are usually talking
about-- in an atomic system--
about very narrow resonances.
And we are working
hard on our lasers
to be close to one resonance.
And it would be an amazing
coincidence if accidentally it
would be in resonance
with another one.
But I would say, if you
had a situation-- let's
say in a molecule, which
is a high density of state,
the Raman process would
be a rotation or vibration
of Raman process involving
the ground state.
And if you're unlucky and don't
choose your lasers wisely,
the two laser photons
could get you high up
into an electronically
excited state.
And this may have some
detrimental effect,
depending what you want to do.
But in general, I would say if
you have more than one process,
there is no interesting
interference term.
You just get two
different rates.
One is the two-photon Raman
rate and the other one
is the two-photon
absorption rate.
And you just have
both simultaneously.
They're not leading to
the same final state.
If something leads to
the same final state--
this is more subtle because you
kind of cram the interference
effects.
But we'll discuss some of those
things in our next chapter
on coherence.
Any other questions?
OK.
I want to now take it one level
higher, where we talk still
about two-photon
processes but we
are allowing one of the photons
to be spontaneously emitted.
Again, we don't have
to learn new things.
We just have to map it to
knowledge we already have.
And let me sort of do
it in the following way.
I just want to sort of give
you a clear understanding what
this expression for
the two-photon rate is.
If we assume laser
one and laser two
are near-resonants with
a transition a to k and k
to b, respectively,
we can sort of
look at the two-photon
process in the following way.
We can say the photon
omega 2 cannot be absorbed
by the initial state.
It can only be absorbed
by the initial state
because omega 1 mixes in with a
certain probability, the state
k into the ground state.
So if you would
first forget about it
and you just do
perturbation theory,
then you would say in
perturbation theory
with the field one,
the state a has now
a probability,
given by this term,
that the state a has
now an admixture.
And now, if we have sort of--
we have dressed up our state
a with admixing for
the near-resonant field
some probability
of state k into it.
And this stressed state now has
sort of a stepping stone here.
And from this stepping
stone, it can now
absorb the photon omega 2.
So that's how we
should think about it.
I'm treating this dressing
up of the initial state
just a perturbation theory.
And that's why everything
was in one formula
when I applied
perturbation theory.
But as we especially cover
in the second semester
of the course, you can also
say if omega 1 is very, very
strong, you can exactly
diagonalize the Hilbert
space of states k and a.
And this is called the
crest atom picture.
But again, what happens is
you mix those two states.
And it is the admixture now
in a non-perturbative way
of state k, which is sort
of the stepping stone.
And from this
stepping stone on, you
can absorb a photon omega 2.
So we could actually--
let me just redraw this--
that we want to go
to the final state b.
But in this kind of
picture I just suggested,
I start with a dress state a.
But what is relevant is
only kind of this admixture.
And from this admixture,
we can absorb omega 2.
The real state k
is somewhere else.
And so it looks like, actually,
now a two-level system,
where we go from
the dashed line--
called the virtual state--
to the final state b.
And let me just point out
what this virtual state is.
Well, you know already
everything about it
because everything which
can be known about it
is what we have
derived in our formula.
I'm just interpreting
the perturbation theory
I've written down to you.
And if I now call
it a virtual state,
there is nothing
more you can ever
know about this state than
what was in this formula.
But it's maybe helpful
to summarize it.
Because we have a resonant
with frequency omega 2
in this situation, it is clear
that the energy of this state
is where the dashed line is.
It's not the energy
of the real state k.
The stepping stone is created
with the first photon.
And the dashed line
is the energy level
of the virtual state.
What is its character?
Spatial bay function and such?
Well, it is exactly the
intermediate state k.
And what is the population?
If you had a
two-level system, we
sort of start with 100%
amplitude in state 1.
But here, our
population is diminished
by the probability at which
we have it admixed the state.
So in other words,
if I really wanted
and I want to use
this concept, I
could make a
simplified description
of two-photon process.
I would just say the
two-photon process is just
a similar photon
process starting
from the virtual state,
and the virtual state
is created by the first photon.
Well, you would say,
well, why do you do that?
I think the picture
I've just drawn
for you is sort of
helpful when we discuss
now two-photon emission--
spontaneous emission.
With two lasers,
it's sort of simple.
But with two-photon emission,
we have the situation
that we start in
an excited state b.
We have one laser,
omega 1, and that's it.
But we will find out that,
eventually, the system
populates the ground state.
And one possible
process-- and that's
the one we are focusing
on is-- that it was first
emitting a photon
in a stimulated way,
but the second photon,
since we're not
offering any extra
stimulation, had
to be emitted spontaneously.
Now, you say, well,
how do I calculate it?
I can write out long equations.
But with the concept
I've given to you,
it should be clear that what
we actually have is here,
we have nothing-- let's
just look at the first part
as a dressed atom,
an atom in state
b with some
admixture of state k.
And this admixutre can now decay
by a single-photon process.
So in other words, you don't
need to re-derive anything.
You can just sort of use
analogy to write down
what is the spontaneous emission
rate out of the state k.
So what you would
write down now is
the rate for this
two-photon emission-- one
photon stimulated, the
second photon spontaneous--
is simply the Einstein
a coefficient,
or the spontaneous emission rate
out of this intermediate state
gamma ka.
But then we have to multiply
with the probability
that this state is
present in the state
b because b-- that's
what we assumed
has no direct matrix
element to emit to state a.
And now you should
sort of be amazed
about the beauty of
concepts you have learned.
We are talking about
something which
maybe before this lecture--
wow, one photon stimulated,
one photon spontaneous.
That must be complicated.
But it's just that,
except for one thing.
And this is the
following-- remember,
you should always remember
how we derived the formula
for spontaneous emission.
The physics of
spontaneous emission
is that you can put one photon
in each of the empty modes
and you have to
sum overall modes.
And what was important
was the density
of modes at the frequency.
And now the frequency is omega.
So when we calculated
the spontaneous rate--
emission rate-- the decay
of the excited state k,
we had an omega cubed dependence
at the resonance frequency--
at the resonant frequency
for the transition ka.
But now we are
interested in the density
of states at frequency omega.
Well, you'll remember,
two factors of omega
are from the density of states.
One came from translating
for momentum matrix
element to-- no, one
was-- yes, it was set.
But one was pretty much the
single-photon Rabi frequency.
And this is also at the
frequency of the photon.
So you just have to correct
for the omega cubed factor.
And this is our result now
for two-photon emission.
OK.
This may be even more relevant
at least in the research which
is done in my group and
in other groups at MIT,
are again Raman processes.
We often have Raman
processes-- you know,
you need a reason why
you want a two-photon.
If you can't reach the upper
state with a single photon like
people in [INAUDIBLE]-- they
may just use two photons.
But this is more
limit because they
don't have the laser,
which can bridge the gap.
In situations where you
work with alkali atoms,
we are often very happy with--
we have one resonant line
and we can do all the laser
cooling, everything we want.
But often, we don't like that
the line width of the excited
state is very large.
And therefore, certain
precision work,
where we want to be very
accurate in what we're doing
with the atoms, cannot be
done on the d1 or d2 line.
And therefore, we often
use a two-level system,
which consists of
two hyperfine states
because then there
is no broadening
to do spontaneous emission.
So one motivation why we again
and again and again consider
two-photon processes
in our laboratory
is because it gives us excess
to very narrow resonances.
But I think you
get the gist now,
and it will become
even clearer later on,
that often when you do a
transition between two ground
state levels, a
lot of the physics
is the same as of
a single photon.
You just replace your
single photon Rabi frequency
by two-photon Rabi
frequency, and suddenly you
can do everything
you ever wanted
to do with a single photon.
But now with the benefit of
having a very narrow resonance.
So anyway, therefore, I think
the most important aspect
of two-photon processes
99% of the research
people in our field are
involved is actually
in the form of Raman processes.
So therefore, but for
pedagogical reasons,
I just like to start out
with two-photon process--
one photon stimulated,
one photon spontaneous.
But now let's just fold it over,
and we have the lambda type
transition.
The first photon is absorbed
and the second photon
is spontaneously emitted.
I think as you
realize when you go
from the two-photon
absorption to Raman process,
there's nothing you
have to re-learn.
You just have to be careful with
the signs of omega 1 and omega
2.
So if I would ask you now
what is the rate-- what
is the rate of the
spontaneous Raman process,
well, it is the probability to
be in the intermediate state.
And this probability
is just re-writing
in a different way what
we have used, is the Rabi
frequency of the first
step squared, divided
by the detuning squared.
So this is the probability
to be in the excited state.
Now, the spontaneous
emission occurs
with Einstein's a
coefficient connecting
the intermediate state
to the ground state.
And then, of course,
as we just learned,
we have to correct the
spectral density and such,
or we have to use
for the calculation
of the density of modes.
The correct omega
factors-- we have
to calculate it at the
frequency of the emitted photon.
This is actually
also-- this kind
of spontaneous
Raman process-- has
been very important
historically.
Before the advent of
lasers, all you had
is light bulbs, strong light
bulbs, maybe mercury lamp
which put a lot of light
into the mercury light,
and at least it was
somewhat spectrally narrow.
But still very, very broad.
And you couldn't really
resonantly, you know,
stack up two light bulbs and
have enough spectral power
to excite to a certain state.
But look here-- you could
still, with a strong light bulb,
create an admixture
of the excited state.
This virtual line
was terribly broad
because of the width of the
light bulb-- spectral width--
but then this spontaneous photon
was just compensating for it.
So in other words, it should
be obvious-- this process only
depends on the power
for the first step.
And it doesn't really
matter if the power
is delivered by a
laser or a light bulb.
The rate for this
process is the same.
And this actually
was the discovery
by Raman, which was rewarded
with the Nobel Prize,
for suddenly observing
when you excited molecules
with a very strong
light bulb, you suddenly
saw very different frequencies
of photons coming out.
And this was a
landmark discovery.
OK, what is next?
I've already written it out.
So that's also important for a
lot of research within the CUA.
When we simply want to change
the momentum state of an atom,
we have two lasers.
We go up and down.
We are not changing
the internal state.
But it is still a Raman
process because state a and b
differ by the photon recoil.
So we're not going
back to the same state.
We are going back to the
same internal state a,
but it may have 2h [INAUDIBLE],
two-photon recoil different.
And therefore, as long
as, in quantum physics,
one quantum number is different,
it is a different state.
And therefore, if you
just think about it
Rayleigh scattering resonance
fluorescence, that you go up
and you go down
to the next state.
You may think you have
your favorite atom,
and you go up on a
cycling transition.
Well, when the atom goes
up and then emits a photon
on a cycling transition,
there is recoil involved.
So actually what you're doing
is on the cycling transition,
you cycle it through many, many
spontaneous Raman processes.
So this is the
correct description
of resonant fluorescence
and Rayleigh scattering.
Any questions?
Good.
I've just mentioned that when
we do Reyleigh scattering,
we have to consider that
the photons have momentum,
and this takes us
to another state.
Let's now be a little
bit more careful
and consider what is
the role of the momentum
in the transition-- in
the two-photon process.
And in particular,
I want to come back
to this Fermi's
Golden Rule formula
and include in this spectral
profile, which in the simplest
case is always the Lorentzian.
But I want to include
now Doppler shifts.
So in other words,
what I want to do now
is I want to talk about
recoil and Doppler shifts
in a two-photon
process and see how
it will affect the line shape.
All we have to do is--
or maybe let me back up.
You should maybe consider
what I've discussed so far,
is the situation of an
atom which has no motion.
We could just fully focus on
the internal degree of freedom.
And just to remind
you, we have discussed
two ways how you can eliminate
motion out of the picture.
One is assume the atom
has infinite mass.
That's one possibility.
The second one is assume
the atom is tightly
localized in an ion trap,
deep in the [INAUDIBLE],
that it is localized to
less than the wavelength.
And actually, the two ways of
how you can eliminate recoil
in Doppler shift are
actually the same.
When I said, give the
atom an infinite mass,
well, you give the
atom an infinite mass
by tightly connecting
it to the laboratory.
And this is what tight
confinement in an ion or atom
trap does.
Because then the recoil is
absorbed no longer by the atom,
but by your
experimental structure,
or by your whole laboratory,
or even by the building,
if you want.
But now, we are kind of going
beyond this restriction.
We are now saying, OK, now
we allow the atom to move.
And we can deal with that by
simply saying when the atom has
a velocity v, we can transform--
we can just use the Galilean
transformation and say OK,
the physics is the same.
However, the atom,
due to its velocity,
sees a slightly
different frequency.
So therefore, we
have our Lorentzian.
But now, we calculate
our Lorentzian
by using the frequencies
perceived by the atom.
The different
signs-- plus minus--
are, of course,
distinguishing whether we
have two-photon absorption
or Raman process.
And the frequency shift, going
into the frame of the atom,
gives us Doppler ts k1v and k2v.
And now you'll see that there is
something which is potentially
interesting, and I
want to discuss that.
If k1 and k2 end up
here with a minus sign,
it may eliminate Doppler
shifts, maybe even completely.
So this is something new.
If you have a single
photon, you always
transfer momentum to the atom.
But if you have two photons,
the two momenta can cancel.
And this is actually
a powerful method
to avoid Doppler
broadening in spectroscopy.
So let me elaborate on that.
The message you get
from this formula--
it's actually much
easier to say it in words
than to write it
mathematically because it's all
hidden in the plus minus sign.
But the gist is that two-photon
absorption or Raman processes--
so any kind of
two-photon process--
they are like
single-photon transitions.
And we've already
discussed it, that we
said we have Fermi's Golden
Rule like for single photon.
It's just we have to use
the suitable definition
of the two-photon
Rabi frequency.
And we had also seen that
we can treat, actually,
the two photons at one.
But the frequencies,
sort of, of this photon--
if you want to regard
the two-photon process
as a super photon, the
frequency of the super photon
is now either the
sum or the difference
off the two
frequencies, depending
whether we look at two-photon
absorption or Raman process.
But what we see now from
the Doppler shift formula,
that we can apply the
same also to the momentum.
It is as if we had a
super photon, which
drives one transition, but the
momentum of this super photon
is now the sum or the
difference of the two
momenta of the photon.
And if you wonder, how
do you sum them up?
What really matters is what is
after the two photons have been
exchanged, what is
the total momentum
transferred to the atom.
So what appears here--
k1 plus minus k2--
is the total momentum
transfer to the atom.
And you see that if you
have two-photon absorption,
if the two laser beams
are counter-propagating,
the total momentum
transfer is zero.
But if you have a Raman process
where you absorb one photon
and then emit it,
the momentum transfer
is zero, assuming similar
frequencies, when the two Raman
beams are parallel.
So in other words, the situation
without momentum transfer--
and you will see in a
moment, or I've already
said this is a situation
where you are Doppler
free-- for two-photon
absorption the geometry is
counter-propagating.
For Raman processes,
it is co-propagating.
Then you have no or minimal
momentum transfer to the atom.
OK.
So this total
momentum transfer is
minimized for k1 equals minus
k2 for two-photon absorption,
or for k1 equals k2
co-propagating laser beams
in the case of
the Raman process.
Oops.
Now you have it twice.
Let me just focus, because
there is very special interest
in that, for precision
spectroscopy of hydrogen.
Let me assume we have just
one laser, which produces--
but we want to dive a
two-photon process with it.
In this situation,
omega 1 equals omega 2.
The momentum transfers
are the same.
And if we arrange
for the two photons
to be absorbed from
opposite directions,
we reach the situation where the
Doppler shift is really zero.
So this is the way where we
do Doppler free spectroscopy.
And two-photon
spectroscopy is one
of the handful of methods
of practical importance
for eliminating the first
order Doppler shift.
So if you take an atom-- and
let me just quote Dan Kleppner
research, where this
is the hydrogen atom--
and you have two laser beams
from opposite direction.
How will the spectrum look like?
Well, we have the feature,
which I just emphasized,
that the two photons-- one
is absorbed from the left
and from the right,
and therefore you
get a very, very sharp line.
Really sharp.
I will talk about
it in a second.
But you cannot, of course,
suppress the process where you
absorb two photons from the left
or two photons from the right.
And therefore, you have
sort of a broad pedestal.
So the pedestal is where you
take one photon-- both photons
from the same side, whereas the
Doppler free peak is where you
have photons from
counter-propagating directions.
Since hydrogen is of
methological importance,
measurements of-- fundamental
measurements of-- the Lamb
shift, comparisons
with QED calculations,
measurement of the
Rydberg constant-- these
are all done by
hydrogen spectroscopy.
So therefore, it
is very important
to have precision method which
suppresses the Doppler effect.
However, let me point out
that once you have completely
eliminated the first
order Doppler broadening,
you are then limited by the
second order Doppler effect.
And as I pointed out,
there is no geometry-- no
arrangements of
beams, no tricks you
can play-- because
one contribution
to the second order
Doppler effect
simply comes from time dilation,
that in the frame of the atom,
relativistically speaking,
the clock ticks differently.
And therefore, the
spectral line is different.
So this is what we had discussed
already for the second order
Doppler effect, and this is
not suppressed by two-photon.
If you now estimate what is
the relative line width-- so
what is the delta, the
line broadening you
to the second order
Doppler effect, in relation
to the transition frequency?
So just give me a second.
Yeah.
Then this omega cancels
and we have an expression
which is sort of interesting.
It is mv squared.
It's the energy--
the thermal energy--
but since we have normalized
it to the transition frequency,
it becomes now
the thermal energy
relative to the rest
mass of the atom.
You would think, well,
this must be really tiny.
Well, it is tiny.
If you take room temperature, it
is 2 times 10 to the minus 11.
But people are now
looking for precision
in optical clocks, which is in
the 10 to the minus 15 range.
So you really have to be
able to know the temperature,
know the kinetic energy
distribution of the atom,
and be able to correct for it.
Or ultimately, if you
can't correct for it,
you would not be able to correct
for it at room temperature
because you can't know for
certain that the velocity
distribution of the
atoms in your laser beam
is exactly at room temperature.
You really have to go
to low temperature,
go to cryogenic temperatures.
And in the famous experiments
in Munich and [INAUDIBLE] group,
the typical situation is
for the 1s to 2s transition,
they observed residual
line broadenings
on the order of a
few hundred Hertz.
This is not limited at all
by the natural lifetime
of the 2s transition.
As you calculate in your
last homework assignment,
the lifetime of the
2s state is actually
due to two-photon emission.
Amazing.
Two photons in series.
This is the way how
the 2s state decays.
And you will, actually, with
this rather simple description,
get a fairly accurate
estimate for the lifetime,
which is a fraction of a second.
And [INAUDIBLE] group uses
a cryogenic experiment.
They cool the hydrogen by
collisions with liquid helium,
cooled vaults, to maybe a Kelvin
or so, three hundred times
below room temperature.
And this has been important
to reach this precision.
And still, I think, even
at Kelvin temperature,
the second order Doppler shift
is one of the important--
is one of the
important systematics.
OK.
This is what I wanted to discuss
with you about two photons.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just--
very lightly-- I
would have thought [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
It really depends what you want.
If you simply want an
atomic clock, all you want
is a very, very, very
stable reference point.
And people use for
that [INAUDIBLE]
and strontium, or
the people who do
ion traps use the aluminum ion.
All they want is
a spectral line,
which is sufficiently sharp,
sufficiently narrow, and also
insensitive to magnetic
fields and electric fields.
And so they select all over
from the whole periodic table
what they want.
But people who want to measure
fundamental constants--
the Rydberg constant--
want to compare lame shift
with first principle
QED calculations,
sort of test the precision
of quantum electrodynamics,
verify that quantum
electrodynamics is
a complete description of
atom photon interaction,
they can only deal
with simple systems
where all the
calculations are possible.
This is the case for hydrogen.
And, actually, with some advance
in the numeric calculation
of wave functions
and all that, it
may also be possible
to do it with helium.
I know in the literature
people have often
suggested helium have
pushed the precision
of two-electron calculations
further and further.
I think so far it
hasn't kind of-- helium
has not replaced hydrogen.
It's still hydrogen.
But this sort of tells
you what the choices
if you want to test
fundamental physics
or determine
fundamental constants.
In all atoms other than
helium and hydrogen,
you would be limited by the
infeasibility of many electron
calculations.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Going back to the
two-photon Raman process where
you had the second
spontaneous emission,
I just want to clarify.
So in the past, all this time
when you were talking about
off-resonant single photon
scattering, was this actually,
really, the more descriptive
picture or was there actually
a different physical--
PROFESSOR: No, this is
off resonance scattering.
And if you ask me, when do
you have a situation where you
first absorb the photon and
then emit it, I would say,
I would like to know that.
I don't think there
is a situation where
this is possible.
You always-- you should always
use a two-photon picture.
Or the only situation, if you
press a little bit harder,
where I think you can
think in first absorption
and then emission,
is if you have a gas
with lots and lots
of collisions,
the first photon may
not be fully resonant.
But then you have a
collision and the collision
stabilised, provides
the missing energy
or takes away the extra energy.
And then with something which is
much more complicated than you
ever wanted, you have
now truly an atom
in an excited state,
which has completely
lost its memory from
how it was excited.
And yes, for this atom,
it will now simply
spontaneously emit a photon.
But in all other
situations where
you don't have any loss
of coherence or something
in between, you're never
really going to the real state.
You're always going
to virtual state.
It's all two-photon.
And, I mean, we discussed that.
Remember the clicker question
where most of the class
was confused when
I said we go up--
if we're exciting the atom?
But now we are asking,
what is the spectrum
of the emitted photon?
It is a delta function
at the drive field,
and we discussed it at length.
If you allow in your head any
picture of first absorption
then emission, that's where all
the wrong answers come from.
This is really the
picture behind it.
This is what happens.
Photon in, photon out--
should be described together,
unless you have-- and I'm
just repeating myself--
something in between,
which is sort
of some form of
de-coherence which
decouples the two processes.
OK.
But that's a wonderful opening
to our next chapter, namely
coherence.
To what extent-- we just
discussed one aspect of it
and we come back to this
in this chapter-- to
what extent is the
photon which is scattered
coherent with the
incoming photon?
So I want to feature,
in this last big chapter
of this course, coherence in all
its different manifestations.
I think this is rather unusual.
I don't know of any
textbook or any other course
where this is done.
But this is similar in spirit to
what we did on line broadening.
I felt I could create
spatial connections
by discussing all possibly line
shifts and line broadenings
together.
And now I hope you will also
see certain common traits
if I discuss together all
the different manifestations
of coherence.
So what we want to
discuss is-- we start out
by talking about coherence
in a single atom.
We can have coherence
between two levels.
Usually, I try to
stop at the simplest
possible manifestation.
But when we talk
about coherence,
I cannot stop at two levels
because there are many new
qualitative features which come
into play when we have three
levels-- like lasing
without inversion,
like electromagnetically-induced
transparencies,
for those of you who
have heard about it.
On the other hand,
I can reassure you,
I don't think there's anything
fundamental to be learned
by going to four,
five, and six levels,
so we will stop at three levels.
We can have-- so this
is a single atom.
But we can also have coherence
between different atoms.
And phenomena we want to
discuss is superradiance,
which is very, very much related
to the phenomenon of phase
matching.
Everybody who frequency
doubles a laser
knows about phase matching
and phase matching conditions.
You have to rotate the
crystal or heat the crustal
to the temperature where
the whole crystal--
all the atoms in the
crystal act coherently.
But it's very related
to superradiance.
There is a third aspect of
coherence between atoms which
I will not discuss
this semester,
and this is the situation
of Bose-Einstein condensates
and macroscopic wave functions.
This is covered together
with quantum gases
in-- this is discussed in
the context of quantum gases
in the second part
of the course.
So having these very different
manifestations of coherence,
I want to try now to give you
a definition of coherence.
But it's a bit
difficult because I
want to cover with my
definition all the cases I know.
But with those examples in
mind, for me coherence--
we have the phenomenon
of coherence.
Coherence exists if there
is a well-defined phase.
Well, if we have a phase--
a well-defined phase--
it's always a phase between
quantum mechanical amplitudes.
So we need two or
more amplitudes.
So coherence exists if there
is a well-defined phase
between two or more
amplitudes, but we can only
observe it if those
amplitudes interfere.
And it can be two amplitudes
describing two different atoms,
or it can be two
amplitudes of two
states within the same atom.
But I will point
out to you-- what
is really relevant is
an indistinguishable
ability that those two
amplitudes are involved
in two branches of a process
which has the same final state.
And like in Feynman's
double-slit experiment,
you don't know which
intermediate state was taken.
And that's where coherence
manifests itself.
So that means when we
observe an interference, that
means we obesrve-- and
this is how we read out
of a coherence-- one
observes a physical quantity,
the population in a
certain quantum state,
total electric field
emitted, but this quantity
is usually proportional to the
square of the total amplitude.
And that means we get
an interference term.
So coherence is important.
Let me provide one
additional motivation
that coherence is an
important technique
and important tool
for measurements.
In a way, it's subtle but
trivial at the same time.
Whenever we do spectroscopy,
we are actually
interested in doing a
measurement of energy.
We want to measure
energy levels.
And those energy
levels can tell us
something about magnetic
fields through Zeeman shifts.
If you're addressing
energy levels
in the gravitational field
for atom interferometry,
the energy levels reflect
gravitational fields.
Or if we are not
interested in-- if we
try to eliminate or shield
the atoms from magnetic fields
and we just want to
get the most precision
in a reproducible
energy level, this
is the situational
of atomic clocks.
So pretty much when we
use atomic spectroscopy
for any application, we are
interested in the energy
levels.
But this is very
deeply connected
to coherence and the phase
because the relative phase
between two states
is nothing else
than the time integral
over the energy difference
between two levels.
So the phase evolved
between the two levels
is the difference frequency
times time or time
integrated dt.
So therefore, when we are
talking about coherence,
how can we maintain longer
coherence between energy levels
or how can we create coherence
in three level systems?
This is actually intricately
related to the fact
that we can obtain more precise
information about the energy
levels.
Anyway, this is a very general
introduction to coherence.
Before I talk about
manifestations of coherence,
I have two clicker questions
because the first form
of coherence I
want to discuss is
the coherence of--
the coherence involved
in exciting atoms and
the atom emitting light.
It's related to the spontaneous
emission and scattering
problem.
So just to sort of figure
out what you know already,
let me ask you something
about the nature
of spontaneous emission.
The first choice is
spontaneous emission,
is nothing else than a
unitary transformation--
unitary transformation or
unitary time evolution--
of the wave function
of the total system.
And option B is
spontaneous emission
introduces-- well, maybe
through a master equations
or optical Bloch equation--
introduces a random phase
into the time evolution of
the quantum mechanical system.
So what is the picture you
have on spontaneous emission?
OK.
Stop.
So at least half of you
better pay attention now.
So the answer is whenever
you have a system
and it couples to the
electromagnetic field--
you just put a system in an
excited state and you wait.
The 100% unique and correct
answer is the system
involves with the
following operator,
and this is the operator we
have discussed many times.
This is the operator
which completely describes
the interaction of an atom
with the electromagnetic field.
And since the whole
system is completely
described by this
Hamiltonian, the whole system
undergoes a unitary
time evolution.
So if you talk about the
total system consisting
of the photons in all
electromagnetic-- in all
relevant modes-- and
the atomic system,
this total
quantomechanical system
has a unitary time evolution
with this operator.
And to the best
what our knowledge,
this is a complete
description which
covers all aspects
of the system.
OK.
But, and this is now
the next question,
there is a certain randomness
in spontaneous emission
when we go to the
laboratory and look
at the spontaneously
emitted photons.
And this is actually
what I want to work out
with you in--
maybe even today, I
think ten minutes
may be enough-- what
is really the information--
the phase information-- which
we have in a photon, which has
been spontaneously emitted.
I know how to phrase--
the randomness
of spontaneous emission.
Well, let me write it down.
First a very big disclaimer.
This question does not
contradict the first one.
The fact that we have a unitary
evolution with this operator
is 100% or 110% true.
But this operator
will actually lead
to final states of the
photon field, which
may not have a specific phase.
So if you say there is
some intuition that there
is something going on with
the phase, you may be correct.
But everything which is
going on with the phase
is the result of a
unitary time evolution.
The system itself is
described by an operator,
by a Schrodinger equation
for the total system.
But the question I have for
you now is if you detect,
let's say, the photon emitted
in spontaneous emission,
the randomness of
spontaneous emission,
the-- let me call
it loss of phase,
or at least the diminishment
of the read out.
There may be situations where
we have a laser beam which has
a well-defined phase,
photons are scattered,
and we just cannot retrieve
the phase of the laser beam
by looking at the photons.
So this is what I mean here.
Also, the photons can't come
out of a unitary time evolution.
My question now is, is the
randomness or this loss
of phase of spontaneously
emitted photons--
and now we should,
I want to know
your best guess--
what is it due to?
Is it only due to
the-- does it only
occur, is it only due
to the measurement
process of the photon?
Or is it due to
performing sort of
a partial trace ever-reaching
over certain states?
So if you're interested
in the photon,
maybe tracing out the
states of the atom.
Or ever-reaching over modes
of the electromagnetic field.
And question C is both
is actually possible.
So if you look at
spontaneously emitted photons
and they're not perfectly
phased coherent--
they're not reproducing
the phase of the laser who
has created them-- what
is the reason for that?
Is it always the
fundamental reason
or is there no
fundamental reason?
It's only a kind of reason of
ignoring information, taking
a partial trace?
OK.
That's pretty good.
Yes.
What I want to emphasize is
that A is very, very important,
and I want to discuss it now.
But B is always the case.
If you ignore the position
where the atom has scattered
the light-- if
atoms scatter light
and they are wavelengths
apart, then you
have maybe optical path
length differences.
The photon from the
laser hits an atom here.
It goes to your detector.
But from another
atom, the photon
has accumulated a different
spatial phase into the IKR.
And, of course, what you get
here is the random phase.
This is why quite
often when we scatter
light for many,
many atoms, we're
not even asking for the phase.
We say, one atom scatters
light-- really scatters light
at a certain intensity, i1.
And n atoms-- well, we
get n times the light.
You immediately perform
an incoherence sum
because you sort of
know deep in your heart
that there won't be
any interference.
So it's always
possible, of course,
to lose the phase
by not controlling
every aspect of your experiment.
So B is always possible.
But for so many reasons that
I don't want to discuss it,
but the measurement
process is very relevant.
And so, therefore, I would
have answered C here.
But let's now discuss the
most fundamental situation.
And the most
fundamental situation
is we take our favorite
atom with infinite mass--
no Doppler shift,
we just put it.
And we put it in a
cavity that it can only
interact with a single mode
of the electromagnetic field.
So this is a
fundamental situation.
And a lot of the
general situations,
you get by just summing
up over many modes,
summing up over many
positions of the atom,
introducing Doppler
effects and all that.
It just messes things up.
And this is more in
the spirit of answer B,
that you perform partial trace
and average over many states.
But let's now
pinpoint what I think
is intellectually the
most important one,
the pure situation
where an atom is just
talking to a single mode.
So let us assume that we have an
atom which starts in the ground
state, but now we
excite the atom.
And we excite it
by a short pulse.
And this can be
a pulse which has
a pulse aimed
between zero and pi.
And depending what
the pulse angle is,
it will admix-- we
have the ground state
and it will admix something
of the excited state.
And in case of a pi pulse, we
have 100% in the excited state.
So our atomic wave
function is this.
The excited state--
let's just assume
the photons are in resonance.
We know how to deal with
off resonant lasers.
So therefore, the
phase evolution
is e to the i omega naught t.
But now, and this is
what coherence is about,
there is a very specific phase.
And this phase phi
comes from the laser.
If you excite the
atom with a laser beam
but it has a phase shift,
then the atomic wave function
is phase shifted because
every amplitude you admixed
into the ground state in
form of an excited state
was driven by the operator--
the dipole operator,
e-- and e, the
electric field, has
the phase of the laser beam.
Sure, there may be-- and kind
of all other trivial factors
I've set to one here.
But there is the phase of
the laser, which directly
is imprinted into the
phase of the wave function.
OK.
So this is what the
atom does-- what
the laser beam does to the atom.
So we have now an atom
which is partially excited.
And it carries is an imprint
of the phase of the laser.
And now after the
laser pulse is over,
the photonic part of the
wave function is a vacuum.
We have no photon in our cavity.
And now we wait and we
allow spontaneous emission.
And spontaneous
emission is nothing else
than the time evolution
with the operator I just
discussed with you.
So after spontaneous
emission, well, one
is we know for sure the
atom is in the ground state.
Let me write down the result.
If we apply the
operator which couples
to the electromagnetic
field, and we
assume only
co-rotating terms here.
Let's just neglect
counter-rotating terms,
which can be-- which in
near-resonants are irrelevant.
What happens is we are now
propagating this wave function.
And the ground state-- with
the ground state of the photon,
does nothing.
However, the excited
state with zero photon,
we discussed that excited
state with zero photon
will actually do
Rabi oscillation.
Ground state with one
photon, excited state
with zero photons.
And so we have now our
knowledge from the vacuum Rabi
oscillation that this part of
the wave function does nothing.
This part of the wave
function undergoes
single photon vacuum
Rabi oscillations.
And if we start out with the
superposition of ground zero
and excited zero, well, this
is a superposition principle
of quantum mechanics.
We can just propagate this part,
and we can propagate that part.
So what I suggest is when we,
really at the fundamental level
now, discuss
spontaneous emission,
we allow this
part-- excited atom,
empty cavity-- to undergo half
a vacuum Rabi oscillation.
And then the excited state
is in the ground state
and the photon state
has one photon.
It's a completely
coherent Rabi oscillation.
I just allow half
a cycle to evolve.
And the result of that is, well,
nothing happened to this part.
And the Rabi
oscillations have now
taken us to the
one photon state.
And it has just
swapped excited zero
to ground state one photon.
So let me write down something
which is really remarkable,
and then we discuss on
Monday-- next Monday--
we discuss how we would
really measure the phase.
But just look at the two
expressions I've underlined.
And this tells us
that the quantum state
of the atom as a two-level
system-- ground excited
state with all the
phase factors--
has been now exactly
matched on the quantum
state of the cavity.
So if you regard ground
and excited state
as a two-level system, every
quantum mechanical subtlety
of the atomic system
has now disappeared.
It's in the ground state.
But everything
which was coherent,
which was a phase which was
interesting about the atomic
system, has been transferred
to the photon field.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you want to
have an alpha e there also?
PROFESSOR: Oh yes, please.
Thank you.
When I said everything,
I meant everything.
Yes.
OK.
So let me write that
down and then we
have-- so this is what I meant.
This is the most fundamental
aspect of spontaneous emission,
that the quantum
state of the atom
has been perfectly matched.
Perfectly mapped onto
the photon field.
And the one thing we have
to discuss on Wednesday
is the whole of the phase phi.
Phi-- we started out by phi
being the phase of the laser.
And if the laser is
in a coherent state,
I will talk about on Wednesday,
in a homodyne measurement
we can measure phi to
any accuracy you want.
We can determine the
phase of the laser
in a homodyne or
heterodyne experiment.
This phase phi has been
now perfectly imprinted
into a two-level
system for the atom.
And now it appears mapped
into a two-level system
for the photons--
the two-level system
between zero photons
and one photons.
But if we are now
doing a measurement
either on the atomic system
or on the photonic system,
we are limited in the accuracy
at which we can retrieve phi.
And this is what we want
to discuss on Wednesday.
And this is what I referred
to as the fundamental limit
of spontaneous emission
because we have not
lost any coherence here.
It's just if the phase
is only imprinted
in one particle--
one particle quantum
physics sets us a limitation.
Oh well, we can read
out the phase phi.
OK.
Any question?
To be continued on Monday.